partir très loin et peut-être une bonne
thérapie pour oublier mais pas forcément
pour se reposer c'est une philosophie
qu'adopter claude guérini il y a
beaucoup de choses intéressantes à
visiter ce week end en ile de france et
notamment à l'est de la région
l'ile-de-france est le berceau d'une
culture qui se rencontrent à tous les
carrefour des départementales
il suffit d'une voiture d'un vélo d'un
billet de train et vous avez ici par
exemple une école de peinture qui s'est
débarrassé en son temps de vie ta
logique pour prendre en charge le
paysage comme tel
avant d'aspirer d impression non loin là
derrière massacre d'une vieille ville
par une transversale qui se veut
pénétrante à mullah vous aurez
l'exotisme d'une culture exposé de chine
différentes pour les noms gîte eu des
attitudes certes mais tellement
identique à la nôtre par les sources
d'inspiration plein
hamelin sujet comme on ne vit pas pu
passer les musiques et éternelle pour la
convivialité
ici vous trouverez de quoi entendre et
de quoi dire de quoi boire
pas si facile à réunir aux nations
mais il n'ya pas que les bavards les
poètes qui ont de quoi faire
il y avoue mois fatigués mais peinant on
bricole à droite à gauche au couple est
bon on va pas mais au fait des balades à
pied vous connaissez bien le on va
visiter pendant là jusqu à puiseaux
nemours il ya différents quoi les world
capital et si le coeur vous en dit vous
pourrez toujours ajouter au kilomètre de
votre labeur les kilomètres de votre
détente vous trouverez souligner dans
votre région
une bonne raison pour additionner aux
efforts de m'associer aux exploits du
dimanche comme ça autrement
oui nous avons ici ne l'est les ja à
l'ouest de galles qualité à vous offrir